eyewitnesses say the shooting inside
this Walmart in Southeastern Virginia on
Tuesday night was terrifying I looked up
and my manager turned around and he just
opened fire on everybody in the break
room and it is by the grace of God that
a bullet missed me not gonna lie I
literally looked at him I saw the the
smoke leaving the the gun and I
literally watched bodies drop by the
time it was over seven people including
the suspected shooter were dead several
others were hospitalized police say the
shooter 31 year old Andre Bing of
Chesapeake worked at the store the
Chesapeake Police SWAT team executed a
search warrant at the suspect's
residence and with the help of the
Virginia State Police we cleared the
house
we have reason to believe that there's
no risk to the public at this time in a
statement President Joe Biden mourned
the deaths and called for quote greater
action on gun violence
the killings come just before
Thanksgiving but also just days after a
mass shooting at an lgbtq nightclub in
Colorado and more than a week after
another mass shooting at the University
of Virginia
that State's Governor a Republican and
gun rights supporter said now isn't the
time to talk about gun control we will
have once the facts and circumstances
are well understood an opportunity to to
take actions today we must stay focused
on families police and the FBI say
there's no danger to the public but
they're looking for tips that might
explain why the shooter took lives on
Tuesday night
Rosalind Jordan Al Jazeera